good morning here i am steve carlton today i
am going to talk
about language learning but
mostly how to learn
english languages but mostly english at home
es and y
u like my videos please subsc
ibe click
for notifications good
anguage learning is not done
above all in the classroom it is done in the
brain
it is done in our heads this is very
important so
where are you it is there that you are going to
learn the language at home in the car or
wherever this is very important and above all
because of the people who  learn English there is
a large amount of content of all
kinds that you can search through the
internet you can use in different
ways to be able to give the brain
the possibility of learning
because here you have to understand that the
brain does not learn through rules of
explanations  brain has a lot of
difficulty remembering
particular details that they are going to learn
forget and then learn again
but through  all this experience is going
to create patterns in the brain
that help us through everything
we have to do in life
and that is why the one who was learning
english with all the
youtube netflix podcasts everything that exists that can
be used  to learn English
you have a great advantage
compared to me, for example, I
am learning grades ayard where
there is not much of this type of
content and with all that the
youtube netflix podcast newspaper articles
you can read listen import a link
make choices  from this
content
you have a great advantage but
we have to understand
how the brain works for example I
thought I like to ski I'm going to ski and
I'm always adjusting by changing
the efforts of my muscles to be
able to ski because there is
the attraction  gravitational not what and I
through many years
of skiing this sport already my body
knows how
and apply them after  After the efforts
to be able to ski through all the
difficulties that there are in the mountain but
if I should think every time or is there a
tree there now it is a little good more
I do not know how this pro says and every time
it is not that it is  all this is already there are
patterns in the brain that can
control my movements it is the same
thing in language learning
through a
lot of listening a lot of reading and if you have
the opportunity to use the language of
speaking if you live in a country where it is
spoken  English, for example, you can of
course use the language to
create patterns, but the mistakes they
are making that now I
am making mistakes in my Spanish voice,
forgetting words,
this is not important because if I would
have the opportunity to
be with you  with Spaniards for 35
days each time it will improve because the
brain will adjust it will change a
little to integrate these stimuli in the
formation of patterns that will
allow  start to speak better well yes as
is the case now
that I haven't spoken Spanish for a long time because I could
make more mistakes I'm going to forget
words but it's not very
important because I understand and that's why
the first goal in learning should
be understanding because if you have
a good level of understanding, which
means many words, even if it is
a passive vocabulary, if you understand
well, you are already calm, calm down,
you are not afraid, because if you do not understand,
this is very huge, this is very
uncomfortable, but yes  you understand well
and you have a little difficulty
expressing yourself well this one is getting better I know
very quickly if you have a good
level of comprehension level that's why
studying English at home you have
to work on listening and reading
well and now for  example before
speaking in Spanish now I decided that
I want to listen to a little Spanish
because I haven't spoken Spanish for a long time
well I
searched
on google  e podcast in spanish well
there are a lot of podcasts in spanish of
all kinds but in english there are even more
subs about the history of greece
about things like science about music
about politics or everything you want
and podcasts and if for example you don't
In my case, you can understand Persian, the
Persian of the language, because I no longer know how
Persian feels and now Arabic.
I use
automatic transcription services
that cost 10 dollars a month and I can
write
Jordi and well, I will receive a
transcript and with the  tracks
transcription and audio I can
study the entire podcast in link to
learn all the words and phrases that
I do not know is the case with podcasts
but
and movies on netflix I can import and
if you are not yet at a level where
you can use this type of
more
advanced content, not more authentic because also
in links or other sites other sites there is
simpler content with more
repetition
at the beginning you have to use content
with many  a lot of repetition
to put in to be able to
also develop this system
and the brain
those patterns
how the language works not according to
explanations that you are going to forget but
that gives the brain a sense of
how this this language works and then
you can build up a vocabulary by
listening to things  more and more important and
also for pronunciation
and to be able to
facilitate the entry of the language in your
head you have to choose content that you
like
where the voice is pleasant for you because
there is all this emotional side if you like
the content if you like the  voice if you
like all this you are already more willing to
integrate this language in your head and it
helps the brain to form those patterns
this control system I do not control
the language for the language
and English well then
it is not to say that it is not worth going
in class
some schools and surely if there are
very good teachers and there are friends
there are many things that can help you
but all the explanations
school lessons are worth nothing
if you don't have enough experience with
the language and it goes through listening
and reading interesting things for you
pleasant voices for you
the brain is little by little acquiring
the language not learning the language
and with this pass  all the explanations
of the class will be even more
effective well
at last I
can recommend two videos of me in
English
you can listen import cast
they are already in link and to learn
words and phrases
if you like my voice because if I don't have
this my voice is better  look for other things or
if you don't like the topic I'm
dealing with ok
good luck bye